you look healthy I know you always
always you haven't always lived the
healthy lifestyle and I worry about you
occasionally but you look good is that
true you're taking care of yourself yes
I'm doing better yeah
I look like crap right now beside the
flu mm-hmm so that's why I look like a
homeless jack-o'-lantern yeah and I'm
sitting next to army so now I look like
Frankenstein's grandmother yeah I turned
41 you turned 40 41 years old yeah okay
I'll see you guys later
I've known you what 20 years yeah you
we've you been coming on my show yeah 20
years good lord
yeah yeah I drank a lot my twenties and
thirties you drank a lot a cartoonish
amount yeah why not
so I turned 40 so I'm getting healthier
and my first album was called party so I
established a reputation for being a
loose cannon so now I'm like juicing
allowed to go to a juice bar and so I
got like cocky being healthy so I'm at
the juice bar and I do a shot of algae
mm-hmm do a shot a weak shot of
wheatgrass a shot of a low shot of
vitamin B vitamin C just load it up too
much so then I start feeling weird my
body it's like god it's like too healthy
then I accuse the guy that juice bar of
roof eating me
I do roofie me man he goes no you just
did it way too many shots so I leave the
juice bar I start vomiting on the street
my body is just like now this is yeah
that's too healthy that's crazy yeah so
a carload of frat guys pulls over and
they go Schwartz in your raging
algae weak rat really so they you can't
fight what you've established thought I
was coming in hot 2:00 in the afternoon
you